hey guys welcome back to another video
and I'm completely sorry for the fact
that I've been posting in a week while
this has been going on recently and I
haven't done a video on it it's because
long story short the hard drive on my
computer is filled a lot of the [ __ ] has
gone missing so I had to remake all of
it luckily I did have some gameplay from
a few months ago or from maybe like
month ago ish and that's probably why
the Flum nail won't be as great yet I
haven't figured out how to like my photo
shops being a [ __ ] it's just being an
[ __ ] right now but basically that's
why I've been gone for the past week
almost almost week and a half many boys
today I'm going to have two videos today
one on the characters and then two on
the dead stream immediately after this
so be on the lookout for that but let's
get right into this but the first thing
on the list is that patch 1.06 has come
out on PC and it should have been out on
Xbox next week but actually they gave it
to us like two days after so thank you
Ubisoft for actually looking out for
those console players next the two lead
characters we talked about weeks ago
were the Centurion in the Ninja were
confirmed in the dead stream as well
they are the shinobi and the Centurion
they will be free for season pass
holders on May 16th and they will cost
15,000 steel if you do not have the
season pass the they will also be in the
beginning of season 2 which is May 16th
the shinobi will be a samurai if in the
assassin group and the Centurion will be
a hybrid for the nuts on top of that we
also have what the weapons look like the
weapon is kind of it looks like for the
shinobi a chain attached to a sickle
where he kind of like whips it around
and throws it also I don't exactly know
the name so do I do apologize for not
knowing that the dissenter ian has a
Gladius a very short sword kind of like
the Warlord's weapon and on his off hand
he does a fastest which is kind of like
an old-fashioned boxing glove kind of
glove looking thing if you've played
Dark Souls you do exactly know what the
safety is I don't know if it will be
used for that exact purpose though
lastly on the list though there is a new
tier of gear called epic which will
raise the gear score cap past 108 anyway
guys I hope you all did enjoyed this
video I'm sorry for not posting and it's
sorry that I'm rushing this I do not
have a lot of time to get these videos
out once this video goes live and then
the next one
after this everything will be smooth
sailing again very calm very dictate a
detailed video not a lot of rushing in
it but like I said the situation was out
of my hands
that's why I couldn't have the videos up
in the past a week I am sorry for that
but we're back guys were rolling anyway
like I said the video next is going to
be the dev stream so hopeful I will hope
I will see you all in the next video as
well in the next couple hours so peace
out guys have a great day